[Music]
it was Charles Darwin who in his book on
the origin of species' said this from so
simple a beginning endless forms most
beautiful and most wonderful have been
and are being evolved he was talking of
course about the theory of evolution
this idea that all living beings know
Charlie Charlie can I interrupt you
there can we go over some of this now
evolution says that people are evolved
from monkeys correct okay well why then
are there still monkeys answer me that
now let's take a look at the humble
banana see this tab here why is that
there it seems almost a little too
convenient don't you think huh now
consider the human eye incredibly
complex super perfect it seems to
suggest a master designer you've really
done how I expected you to be well I
I've been told I bear a striking
resemblance to the famous and handsome
youtuber Cayenne one firm sorry it's fun
science fun sciences decide so firm yeah
okay people time to get down and dirty
today I'm going to dispel some common
misconceptions about evolution firstly
the idea that human beings evolved from
monkeys is just flat-out wrong we are
however very closely related although
our nearer relatives are other species
of ape like chimpanzees gorillas and
orangutangs in fact just like all of
those animals human beings are Apes too
so a better question to ask is the how a
me and my monkey friend related well if
we go back in time far enough we'll find
the animal from which me and my monkey
brother are both descended our common
ancestor we can take the same idea all
the way back to the ancestors between
humans and birds and humans and trees
and humans and bacteria in fact all life
on Earth is related in this same way
forming what's known as the Tree of Life
speaking of things we have in common
with monkeys let's talk about the banana
now while it might seem like a pretty
nifty coincidence that it has a
Tabb much like the one you can find on a
can of soda unlike a can the banana was
not designed side note you can forget
the tab thing as in nature monkeys
actually open bananas from the other end
instead the reason that bananas and all
other fruits came into existence is down
to something called coevolution which is
where one organism affects the evolution
of another here's how it happened one
day a tree grew with a random mutation
in its genetic makeup
its seeds were encased inside a tasty
fruit this is actually what most bananas
used to look like although modern
varieties of banana as sterile so they
don't have seeds anymore then Along Came
animals who ate the fruit pooped out the
seeds and those seeds grow into new
trees the tastier the fruit and the
easier it was for the animals to eat the
more of those trees were produced and
that's how natural selection selected
the banana a key thing to bear in mind
when it comes to evolution though is
that while it is amazing it does have
its downsides in fact the human eye is a
great example of this because while it
might seem perfect it actually has a
pretty major flaw you see the eye did
the vast majority of its evolving under
water it started with a rudimentary
patch on a bacteria that could detect
the difference between light and dark so
it could see something a bit like this
this allowed the bacteria to detect the
harsh sunlight and swim away from it
which helped it to survive slowly but
surely evolution added a lens and the
eye was crafted over millions of years
it was simple really the better you
could see the more likely you were to
not die however there was one catch the
eye evolved underwater so it was built
to deal best with the way that light
reflects under the ocean surprisingly
dry thus when animals finally came to
land their eyes didn't really work
properly they simply weren't used to the
way that light reflects in air so the
picture these first land animals saw was
much worse than their underwater
ancestors since then our eyes have
gotten better equipped for life on land
but we weren't able to go back in time
and evolve a brand new eye to work best
up here
thus sadly the fishes will always be
able to see a little bit better than we
can so does that clear
things at paws yes you've explained
yourself very well but answer me this
okay so why aren't other animals as
evolved as we are you know take for
example the ugly little slug
he's been around just as long as we have
where are his arms where his legs
Alwyn where's his brain window as his
house got evolution is about survival
right it doesn't matter how you evolved
so long as you can adapt to live in your
environment then you are just as evolved
as anyone else in fact you are just as
evolved as this banana you actually
share 50% of your DNA with this thing
it's almost like it's a family member of
yours what are you doing you cannibal
this is my bloody family monster period
electron thank you very much for
watching also thank you to my friend Kai
and for being my Darwin in this video
very good Darwin that didn't really know
anything about evolution that was the
joke Christmas it's one month away which
means it's time to buy a little
Christmas present and I hear that zoella
she's probably got a new book out or
something hasn't shaved but if you're
short for if they're sold out or
something then this is pretty good too I
promise it's come sit down why did no
one tell me anyway doesn't matter thank
you for watching bye bye